[Applaudissements]
oui
jamais atteint le commence par quoi on
commence par l'eau ça c'est long les
trois c'est lolo et 3 attention ne me
croyez l'abus d'alcool est donnée aux
attentions
madame envoyé gentiment le disque
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les yeux attention maintenant le sucre
de canon
[Musique]
allez zou et enfin visitation
on mélange est là les vrais cas mais il
va boire il veut voir un petit peu
camille avec plaisir avec le jeu de
chaussettes allait alléger mon cas mais
dites-nous si c'est bon c'est non alors
c'est pas si mal je suis il prend goût
si tu lisais pas dégueu mais bon ya
trois ans vous pourrez vous réveiller
les yeux ouverts mais par contre vous ne
pourrez plus bouger vos pieds et vos
pieds gauches et le droit seront
simplement immobilisé au sol ses avocats
me jacques aux témoins ont fait la
chronique
bravo camille
[Applaudissements]
il est bloqué là c'est de bouger votre
pied gauche moment c'est impossible et
le pied droit c'est pareil et
normalement il est très réfractaire un
camille 1 mais encore ça va c'est les
pieds parce que si on prenait le bras
droit et qu'on faisait simplement comme
ça aussi figé fx est soudée mais
simplement le bras droit ayman endroit
est comme un rail de chemin de fer
solide comme du plomb et là impossible
de bouger votre bras droit votre bras
droit et maintenant est occupée dans
l'espace un petit peu ça va vous que
michel une angoisse soit 6